used to say that she joins us now hello
to you maria first of all
congratulations on the nobel peace prize
i'm guessing when you set this up uh
four and a half years ago you weren't
expecting this
you know we're coming up on almost a
decade by january but definitely not
expecting it and uh i never expected how
much journalism and the delivery
platforms for journalism would have
changed
tell me more about your website and the
work that you do
so you know when we set it up uh the
mission the elevator pitch was very
simple we build communities of action
and the food we feed communities is
journalism and the way we deliver it is
technology we embrace technology and
that was probably part of the reason
that we were among the first to really
realize how social media which now is
the world's largest delivery platform of
news how that has become weaponized and
used by authoritarian style leaders to
actually
it's i called it death by a thousand
cuts of our democracy essentially
eroding facts and then without facts you
have no sense of what reality is staring
apart our shared reality
what resistance have you come up against
uh tremendous you know for how how did
democracy crumble uh that's really the
story right not only do you have the
rise of authoritarian style leaders like
duterte
i've been a journalist for 35 years
started in broadcast journalism and you
know in the last in about two years less
than two years i received ten arrest
warrants it's become far more dangerous
has required far more to just do our
jobs and then in addition to that
our audience the people we serve are
actually not getting their news
undiluted it's great that you're on
television but if you are online you
know everything has been commodified and
social media has become a behavior
modification system
what does the philippines government
what what reaction have you you had from
them and i suppose the president but
particularly um has he reached out to
you at all
he hasn't although it took three days
before the presidential spokesman uh
acknowledged congratulated me for being
the first filipino but then reminded me
that you know i have criminal cases the
government is pursuing
all told the maximum jail sentence i i
could go to jail for more than 100 years
so for the rest of my life but also
beyond that the government took credit
saying that the nobel this prize shows
that press freedom is alive and well in
the philippines
so what do you do to stay out of jail
i keep doing my job
you know i
2019 i was arrested multiple times and i
had to spend almost 90 percent of my
time with lawyers i've learned a lot and
it's not just the individual countries
but also international law that needs to
protect journalists more
and we continue to do accountability
journalism investigative journalism
because it's while it's become harder to
hold power.count this is the time when
the mission of journalism has become
even more important
and what will your peace prize mean do
you think of anything uh to the um
obviously a great deal to you and for
the people that work with and and for
you but what about for the uh wider
community you say that the government's
uh accepted praise um for this award
coming to your country
um
we've all felt an incredible boost of
energy you know this is like turning the
sun's rays
eliminating the darkness so we have we
are gearing up for may 2022 presidential
elections so you have a lame duck
president right it's the tail end of a
six-year term for president duterte but
i think beyond that i've spent the last
week or so talking to journalists in
venezuela in mexico in india in pakistan
in the united states in japan
journalists who feel under threat
journalists who feel that they have had
to make so many more sacrifices just to
do their job